l'affirmation qu'on entend constamment
dans les médias à savoir que la hausse
des seuils d'immigration permet de
combler la pénurie de main d'oeuvre elle
est factuellement fausse et erronée 185
mille chômeurs 270 mille postes vacants
il est évident que réduire aujourd'hui
les seuils c'est pas aller dans la bonne
direction l'immigration est elle ou non
une solution à la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
les experts ne s'entendent pas
[Musique]
statistique canada a publié une étude
sur le sujet en juin et sont constants
est assez claire les travailleurs
immigrants permettent de combler les
pénuries dans plusieurs secteurs de 2010
à 2019 à l'échelle du pays ils ont été à
la source de 55 % de la croissance
observée dans les emplois moyennement et
vêtements spécialisés les immigrants
récents qui sont au canada depuis dix
ans au moins occupent actuellement de
nombreux postes qui sont difficiles à
pourvoir
[Musique]
l'an dernier il comptait pour 8% de la
population active mais le présentait 13
% des employés dans le secteur de la
restauration et de l'hébergement et 10%
dans la fabrication et le transport au
québec près d'un emploi sur cinq est
occupé par un immigrant ce qui est
supérieur à leur poids démographique
dans la province si à court terme
l'immigration permet de combler des
emplois certaines études parlent d'un
effet presque nulle à long terme
ont fait valoir que les immigrants vont
aussi faire grimper la demande pour des
biens et services en santé ou en
éducation par exemple et qu'il faudra
davantage de travailleurs pour répondre
à leurs besoins mais une chose est
certaine avec les seuils d'immigration
actuelle promis par les différents
partis politiques le poids démographique
du québec au sein du canada est voué à
diminuer pour le maintenir à 23% il
faudra que yi he plus de 5000 immigrants
dans la province l'an prochain pour
tenir compte du fait qu'ottawa veut
accueillir près de 450 mille nouveaux
arrivants en 2023